this is the entire MCU catalog 29 Movies
9 series one special and 105 hours of
content being shoved down our throats
with plenty more to follow I
and here's what I learned it sucked
sometimes but not in the way you might
think
I'm not going to come out here and tell
you Marvel movies suck because the
writing has gone downhill or because of
bad CGI or a lack of character
development just like every other
YouTuber out there the MCU sucks for a
different reason it sucks because Marvel
made a bet I bet that we all kinda hate
but one that really paid off
[Music]
why does the MCU suck when Kevin feige
and David maisel decided to create the
first modern movie based on Marvel
comics with the film Iron Man they did
so with the intention of crafting an
entire Cinematic Universe which means
that from the very beginning Marvel made
a bet that we as the audience would be
willing and excited to sit through a
slew of movie titles throughout the
years in order to understand everything
that's happening in the most recent
release they've also doubled down on
this bet in recent years with the
introduction of TV series special
presentations and shorts on Disney plus
you might be thinking to yourself I kind
of like all the Marvel content we've
gotten and I agree I love it so why does
it still suck well the reason lies in
the fact that this MCU the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is formally split up
into phases but to explain all that I'll
have to go back
all right
the year is 2006. John Favreau was just
named as the director for Marvel's
upcoming film Iron Man and Robert Downey
Jr was named as the lead character Tony
Stark yes John Favreau the man with very
little directing experience and Robert
Downey Jr the man with the history of
heavy substance abuse and alcoholism
these two were chosen to lead the charge
in the newly formed Marvel Studios first
film Iron Man which again was a pretty
risky character Choice since Iron Man
was hardly a household name at the time
one of the craziest things about this
film though was the way it was scripted
it wasn't that's right Marvel Studios
was betting their entire planned
Cinematic Universe on a film that was
going to be shot without a script and it
worked this multi-million dollar student
film turned out to be a huge success
bringing in over 580 million dollars
worldwide it turned out that this
improvisational way of filmmaking
resonated with audiences and It
ultimately changed the superhero
industry into what it is today in fact
this line one of the most well-known
lines from any superhero movie was
ad-libbed by Robert Downey Jr truth is
I am Iron Man
with the resounding success of Iron Man
Marvel execs decided to push forward and
crafting their Marvel Cinematic Universe
with Kevin feige at the helm they did so
by planning out three main phases with
several more to follow in feige's mind
the overarching story between these
first three phases would be called The
Infinity Saga culminating in
back-to-back Avengers films Infinity war
and end game this brings us to how the
MCU kinda sucks don't get me wrong I
absolutely love the MCU and most of the
films we've been given but to understand
even the first major crossover event The
Avengers you had to watch five films
before that and to understand the
biggest crossover we've been given in
Avengers end game you had to watch 21
films before that this has led to what I
call Blockbuster fatigue and no I don't
mean the way you would feel when the
local Blockbuster didn't have a copy of
Iron Man and you had to settle for the
low budget off-brand Metal Man by
Blockbuster fatigue I mean how many
audiences feel obligated to see every
new Marvel Blockbuster after just so
they aren't missing out on something
important and understanding the next one
I mean imagine a new action movie comes
out about a man on a train but to
understand it you have to watch 20
movies about this character before that
one I doubt many people would be willing
to do this so why are we willing to do
it with Marvel the answer lies in the
BET Marvel made that we would want to
see the full story in essence it lies in
storytelling
phases one through three dubbed the
infinity Saga probably one of the
greatest overarching stories across
films that the world has ever seen with
just a few pitfalls sure the
storytelling got lazy at times and
sometimes character stories went
backwards instead of forwards but phases
one through three really captured the
world's attention in a way that had
never been done before we were
introduced to our favorite comic book
characters on live action for the first
time then Marvel brought them together
to fight against an alien invasion
continued to expand this Cinematic
Universe and then killed off half of
everyone we had grown to love audiences
were stunned I was stunned we had just
sat through 19 movies and all of that
was wiped away then Marvel came back at
us with Avengers end game three hours
and two minutes of absolutely amazing
filmmaking the world was saved Thanos
was stopped and we said goodbye to both
Captain America and Iron Man in 20
minutes of some of the most
heart-wrenching scenes I've ever watched
in a superhero film I thought there was
no way Marvel could top this one in and
I was really happy with their well
thought out conclusion for the MCU it
was over and Disney had no reason to
make a Marvel movie ever again
okay they weren't done phases four
through six dubbed the Multiverse Saga
seems to be trying to one-up the
infinity Saga and take the stakes to the
next level so rather than putting the
whole universe at risk it's the entire
Multiverse at risk now which is kind of
annoying I talked about this in my video
on Doctor Strange too but one of the
traps Marvel has fallen into in recent
years is the thought that every movie
has to raise the stakes from the last
one which is absolutely not the case I
think most audiences appreciate a more
grounded conflict not every movie has to
be a world ending or Universe ending
threat the only reason this works a bit
is because audiences know that Marvel
isn't afraid to kill off half the
universe so these world-ending threats
actually have a little bit of Merit but
this isn't the only issue in phases four
through six in phase one we saw six
movies across four years but in that
same amount of time in phases four
through six we will have seen at least
16 movies and at least 13 TV shows that
is a huge difference and I know marvel
is going to be losing a lot of viewers
because of it but who am I to say it
seems to be working out very well for
them in fact other franchises have tried
to make cinematic universes like Marvel
but almost all of them have failed the
Dark Universe the dceu the Snyder verse
the monsterverse and tons more the only
franchise that's come close to the MCU
is Star Wars which is also owned by
Disney and has started to adopt the same
model of pumping out tons of content for
their beloved Cash Cow everyone else
seems to crash and burn because they
fail to remember what made Marvel
successful in the first place
storytelling in the first three phases
of the MCU they took their time
introducing us to new characters and
developing them before bringing it all
together for the biggest crossover of
all time that isn't easy to replicate it
takes time and care which most
franchises don't have when they try to
compete with Marvel almost always
character introductions are rushed and
not given the care they need for a
worthwhile payoff later down the line
something Marvel whole hardly understood
from the beginning so why does the MCU
suck because we have to watch every new
movie it's not that we don't want to
watch them I really do enjoy everything
that MCU has been putting out it's the
fact that we as the audience have to
watch every new title just to stay up to
date on the MCU and to maintain our
understanding of the Marvel universe as
a whole with Marvel giving us the
biggest Cinematic Universe ever it's
both a blessing and a curse it sucks but
I love it so I'd happily watch every
Marvel movie again and I probably will
just not for a while
check out the video on your screen for
some more of my content also don't
forget to hit the Subscribe button and
like this video if you haven't already
thanks for watching Rocket Riley
[Music]